[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today hi how
are you guys doing today doing well how
are you uh I'm doing all right just
getting a little stressed okay I feel
that what's going on um so my situation
is a little two-part um I've been
listening long enough um to know a
little bit of how to get out of that but
I I'm I keep starting budgets and don't
know how to stick to them and then they
kind of fall apart life happens uh and
the second part of that is I know the
easiest way is to increase income um and
in my position I keep hitting this brick
wall of you're overqualified and don't
have enough experience in stuff like
grocery or you know trying to pick up
extra shifts at like a local restaurant
doing server work or that kind of stuff
so I I don't know how to they're saying
you're overqualified when you try to get
that extra jobs I see I've had a
McDonald's tell me face to face yeah
you're way over qualified to ever work
here do you tell them hey this is not my
B all end all I'm just trying to make
some extra cash um I have told some
yes all of than that so hey before Jade
answers because she Jade's Jade's just
the Guru at walking people through this
in both of the scenarios you just
painted you've you've kind of cornered
yourself as this as this tragic victim
in this
story and you a whole bunch of money and
you're running up against some
roadblocks but I want you to you got to
change your psychology on this or it's
just always going to be too heavy does
that make sense it does like you're it
feels like you're going through life and
life keeps happening to you instead of
you saying No this is my one precious
Reckless life and I'm going to live it
all the way I'm going to go all in right
and that means like I'm not going to let
an assistant manager at McDonald's tell
me I'm overqualified I'm going to
convince them I need to work and I'm
going to work harder than anybody you
got on staff and I got 15 you see what
I'm saying like it's just a matter of
I'm not I I just refuse to be a victim
in this story and so I want you to
change your psychology there and Jade
will walk you through it she's the she's
the goat at this um but let's let's
throw your shoulders back man stand up
tall and like we're going to go head on
and deal with this problem hey how old
are you I'm 32 okay 32 and what's your
what's your your real
job um so I'm a full-time videographer
okay videographer and is it your
business or you work for
I work for a company okay so what would
it look like if if if you really are
getting these doors closed in your face
if I were in your shoes I'm always one
that if I'm looking for some side hustle
work I'm going to do the thing that's
directly related to what I already know
how to do because I probably already
have connections I already know I love
doing it and I can charge more because
I've cut out the middleman you know what
I'm saying so what would it look like
you going out and getting some clients
and you videoing some weddings and you
being at the bar mitzvah or whatever it
is are you able to do that say again so
it's funny you say that I do that on the
side um and it just it doesn't bring in
enough for me to I have kids I guess I
left that part out I have kids how many
um and so it's kind of four is it just
you or do you have a wife uh I'm
divorced okay so you're saying it's a
time is it a time constraint is that the
problem um not so much as a time
constraint as much as um I save money
and then you know kids need new clothes
or new shoes or right but that's a
budgeting issue that's a budgeting issue
and we'll talk about that are the kids
with you fulltime or do you guys split
it 50/50 how does that work um they're
with Mom full-time and I'm kind of at
this point I'm the cash cow okay you go
again there you go back into your like a
corner quit me the catch cow well wait a
minute because yeah you have four kids
you need to pay for them oh absolutely
okay I just wanted to the way you said
it made it seem like you were kind of
mad that you had to pay for your kids
I'm just saying the way it came across
you might not have Meed that way I
forgive you no not at all okay moving on
I
don't moving on here's what I number one
I wholeheartedly agree with John because
it's kind of like I tried this I hit a
wall it didn't work wo was me I tried
this I hit a wall it didn't work wo was
me rarely will it work the first time
like usually you have to keep swinging
and swinging and knocking and knocking
and kick these doors down cuz nothing
gets just and you you know this nothing
is handed to you and nothing is free and
no almost nothing is easy you know and
so I really want you to go hey I like
look in your look in the mirror tonight
and go this is going to be
hard this is going to be really hard and
once you've just been real with yourself
it's like okay now let's go this is not
going to be easy this is a season and
it's going to be tough once you admit
that then it's like We're Off to the
Races so keep knocking on the door doing
the videographer work then go get you an
instacart job too now you're making more
money I want you on a budget here we do
an every dollar budget um I want you to
download it you can download it for free
on your own tonight and then once you
have the budget those things that are
what I would call just normal monthly
expenses that come up will no longer be
these things that throw you off your
game and you're having to dig into your
savings because on the every dollar
budget you'll be able to say okay I
bring in an x amount of dollars each
month so how much money do you bring in
each
month uh about three 3,000 after taxes
and insurance perfect so at the top of
your budget it'll there's a place for
you to put income you'll put $3,000 then
there's a place where you can list
everything that you could ever think of
spending money on in a month and it will
do the math for you so you're going to
spend that
$3,000 on paper or on digital paper on
purpose so December's coming up I want
you to say okay I'm making a budget for
December how am I going to spend this
$3,000 and it's you're starting with the
the four basic walls right your your
rent and your transportation and your
utilities and your food that's first and
then you go back through the next most
important items and then you make sure
to write all the things that your kids
might need and look at their feet do
they need new shoes if you see okay the
shoes are getting worn out I'm going to
start putting aside a little bit of
money for that but when you give this
money a plan suddenly it's like okay I
see where it's going and like you said
you can identify it's it seems like it's
a little bit of an income problem and
maybe it's a little bit of a I just
needed a plan problem hold on it sounds
like it's a massive massive income
problem yeah it is it is you're right
bro you make 50,000 bucks total 40 48
probably yeah and that's including the
side the side
hustles yes with four
kids yeah bro your your your videography
dream is
over I I I'm I'm not playing you got to
go make some money you can be an
assistant manager at McDonald's and make
that money that's
real like you got to let that dream go
dude you got four kids and you're
drowning in in debt how much do you
owe uh total debt about 140,000 holy
smokes dude okay okay okay yeah the
dream's over man or at least it's on
pause you can't afford their life you
can't afford it so you said you're
overqualified what makes you
overqualified what degree do you have
what what are they seeing on paper so I
have a bachelor's degree
in uh mass
communications um I used to work in news
uhhuh um and news doesn't pay very well
right we know that neither does whatever
you're doing
now it pays a lot more than news all
right this is a wakeup call yeah this is
a wake up call Cuz here's the problem we
can tell you all day I'm getting mad we
can tell you all day long here's a
solution here's a solution if you don't
want to see the solution there is no
solution you see what you want to see
you go through life and you can look for
reasons that you can or you look for
reasons that you can't right now dude
you are looking for every single reason
that you can't and you will find it
every single time but I promise you the
moment that you wake up and you say I
want to see reasons that I can do this
you will start to see them this is all
going on upstairs you have told yourself
that you've lost and you have told
yourself that you are the victim and
there's no getting out of this and only
you can control that John and I can tell
you till blue in the face there's
options here you can look at this you
can look at that but we can't we can't
be the ones to change your mind and we
can't be the one to tell you we can only
tell you you can do it we can't go out
and do it for you we can't do it for you
so you've told yourself I won't do it I
won't do it that's what you told
yourself and I'm telling you you can say
you won't but don't tell me you can't
people pull themselves out of holes
every single day holes deeper than yours
they go out and they work and they get
it done because they know they can do it
and they know they need to do it this is
the ramsy show create your free every
doll budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life